when you start to think about uh mining
on the geopolitical scale if you will so
we've got el salvador there in the game
now with the volcano mining china
obviously was doing all kinds of stuff
i'm not gonna say where i know this from
but venezuela they're mining there's
other countries that are mining sure
maybe not the most friendly to the
united states what do you think is the
milestones or inflection points where we
go from maybe countries that are not so
friendly to the united states and or
small countries like el salvador mining
to
everyone's money like what's gonna take
for the united states to start mining
the united states is already mining okay
maybe maybe
i know they might have like 10 or 20
megawatts running somewhere in the
midwest to test it out maybe
it's hypothetically speaking but it's
it's a matter of national security right
when it comes to mining when you're
talking about what bitcoin is right
whether it's a store of value it's or a
medium of exchange it is the future
financial instrument that many many
things are going to be built on top of
uh
nations would have to be
absolutely out of their mind to not be
getting some exposure to the underlying
infrastructure which supports it so the
us i think is on the front foot we've
done we've had a lot of conversations
with
the government in dc state governments
to help to educate them but they are
very forward-thinking when it comes to
to supporting this but i think that what
we're going to see and we're seeing it
already is nations around the world who
want to move from the third to the
second to the first class right they
want to become these first world
countries they now know that being early
with this will take them there the move
in el salvador is going to be a big one
that proves out in 20 to 30 years i want
to play a game with you uh let's call
it's called like uh story poker okay and
so i'll tell you one story then you got
to tell me one in return so i know for a
fact that there's a federal law
enforcement agency that was mining
bitcoin in
2012 2013 very early on uh and what they
realized was uh they couldn't get the
budget to go buy bitcoin in one of the
exchanges and then use that in
undercover operations
so what they did was it was very easy
though to get budget approved by
computers sure of course you need
computers so they bought mining
equipment they mined the bitcoin it also
was untraceable
because it was basically you know virgin
bitcoin if you will and then they would
take that bitcoin and they would use it
in undercover buys et cetera they could
trace it
somebody who uh participated in this
told me this one time after they had
left wow i was blown away i was like man
it's and not only to be doing it the way
they did it it made sense um kind of uh
in hindsight as to why they would get
computers approved versus go purchase
directly uh but also to be doing it that
early
very very good your turn you tell me a
story
so this is how you get in trouble
but i will say there is a there is a
north african country uh that
was a a hot spot for
for the united states a few years ago a
movie was made about it there may have
been some emails that a person didn't
manage properly that caused some issues
um
and they are now getting into bitcoin
mining and uh
it's actually at the presidential level
that they are they're looking to do this
um
there's also you know i live in latvia
for the majority of the year there's a
very close neighbor of latvia that uh
you know
may have stopped a plane not too long
ago to remove a journalist um they're
mining bitcoin with nuclear power so you
have countries now that i mean compass
can never serve because of lists and and
sanctions
they are all mining bitcoin and i don't
believe that they're mining bitcoin to
skirt sanctions i believe that they're
mining bitcoin because they see it as
the future and they want to they want to
boost their economy they want to they
want to grow correct grow that wealth
why aren't they talking about it
publicly
why would you most most miners don't
talk publicly about their operations
because it's just a threat vector right
if you're not a public company that
needs to pump your stock why talk about
it at all stack in silence and just be
happy with that yeah all right i got
another story for you a lot of people
don't know that uh north korea one of
the biggest revenue sources now comes
from either hacking exchanges or mining
as well okay if they basically have
access to it i've read a number of
reports that have talked about how they
um
they have sanctions they're cut off from
the global financial system there's ways
that they can do other things that end
up being pretty effective uh when you
look at places like venezuela north
korea uh
others um
it feels like those countries are doing
it out of
necessity right
developing nations they're not bad
actors they're not adversaries actually
necessarily to the us they're also doing
it out of necessity they want to move
forward their economy
when do maybe non-us developed nations
what is france or spain or the uk when
do they get in the game not because it's
a necessity but because like we're going
to get rich right we're going to benefit
from this economically and it is uh more
so the innovator's dilemma and we're
going to disrupt ourselves on purpose
because we see this as the future versus
we got no other shot at you know
leapfrogging all these countries so like
screw it let's go all in and see what
happens they'll probably be late right i
mean this is all cyclical so you're
going to see the countries that are that
are the first movers that are forward
thinking they're going to get into the
game and by the time the bigger
established countries want to get in
you know they'll they'll come and
they'll throw a bunch of money but
they'll be late to it so the united
states i think will be among the first
of the developed nations to come out in
support of bitcoin mining just because
it's a massive and you're talking about
a multi-billion dollar industry now
within the borders that they're able to
tax they're not gonna you know shun that
revenue or send it somewhere else um
france germany
the social estates of europe
is going to take them a while i mean
they they creep their government creeps
it moves very very slow yeah well they
all got suits and ties and act really
important i got two more questions and
then we'll let you go uh first is talk
to me about the energy mix uh so we've
seen obviously all the nonsense about
china sure now we've got uh texas is
becoming a huge hot spot number places
in the midwest uh here in the us we've
got the bitcoin mining council we've got
people publishing energy mix like just
what's your read on the whole
is it environmentally friendly is it not
does it matter uh what is the mix like
how do you think about it so when i
think about energy just in general right
when you talk about the advancement of
any society it requires the consumption
of as much energy as possible the one
thing that we're going to start to see
in the united states because of like the
decommissioning of power plants we're
going to see rolling blackouts right
business cannot happen if there's no
power for buildings so we're seeing new
york and california and other places be
impacted and we'll continue to see that
um so where i my read on what you know
the energy consumption of bitcoin is
that it's a feature and not a bug we
want the network to consume as much
energy as possible now when it comes to
the mix that people are using bitcoin
miners are always going to gravitate
towards the most plentiful cheapest
sources of energy and for the most part
those tend to be renewable those tend to
be hydro those tend to be nuclear so
we're going to see the gravitation
towards those naturally
you know the information that's being
put out by different actors whether it's
the bitcoin mining council
or these other public companies uh they
all have motives for why they're doing
this you know my guess is that when it
comes to let's say the bitcoin mining
council and
you know michael saylor has done a lot
for bitcoin so not to pick on him too
much but when you think about blackrock
right which is a big owner of
microstrategy's shares
they are big proponents of esg
and
having someone on your cap table or
someone that holds that much of your
your uh your available shares that's a
proponent of something it's going to
force your hand on certain matters which
i think is why he's been involved and he
is now on the you know the front foot
trying to put more information out about
the energy mix that bitcoin's using
talking about to finish up the
decentralization of the network uh
60 plus percent was in
china and other asian countries now it
seems like maybe the us has got like 25
or so
of the mining we've seen wyoming
recently come out so they want five
percent of the hash rate we've seen
texas come out and say that they want
fifty percent of the hash rate yeah yeah
uh we see other countries that obviously
are getting in the game um how do you
think about uh decentralization is there
a healthy percentage that a country
should have should we be concerned if
all of a sudden the u.s had 75 percent
like would that be a downside like just
how do you think about that bitcoin's
non-state money right so if you take
the ability to print
cash from any government you steal their
thunder i think that it's very dangerous
for an overwhelming majority of
bitcoin's hatchery to be located within
any country any country's borders i
think that you know before it was 60
percent in china we're going we're going
to see it creep up on 60 in the united
states and bitcoiners will again be up
in arms about the fact that there's too
much hash rate within
america's borders what we will also see
though is a diversification out of these
two main countries we'll see some in
canada we'll see in the united states we
will see in south american countries
and what i think will be the natural
effect is that bit corners will then
focus attention on new developing
nations where they can put this hash
rate and those nations will be open to
welcoming it because they understand
what a boon it will be for their economy
to bring that in so decentralization is
very important having too much hash rate
within any country should worry every
bitcoiner but i think that as just a
function of this market bitcoiners will
naturally look to to move hash rate out
of countries that are amassing too much
of it how much of your business is in
just the united states versus other
international countries so the majority
of our customer base is in the united
states the majority of the hash rate
that we're managing for customers uh is
split basically between the us canada
and russia we have a big part of our
machines that are running in russia
right now
and do you own the real estate
i know where you're hosting these same
mcdonald's bro no i'm just airbnb right
think of it like airbnb so these
facilities come to us and they say hey
look i've got this space we verify them
right we make them a super host if you
will yep and then they can list on our
site